name's Antos a maison de tous
hey good morning millenials good morning
ma'am Leni Oh what's up hey guys welcome
to the show this is monumental the
morning mames take over the morning
memes take over with the man who came
with the name good morning Millennials
before he realized it was a show about
aliens coming down to earth
pretending to fit in I get my check
every week my ten cents good it's good
how do you feel being here we've done
podcast before but mames has never been
live in studio and I'm freaking out it
feels good feels right it feels right
I'm a long time coming it has been and
you know IOE
I never really like wanna ask you
because I know you're a busy man but
today just felt like the day you know
Zach EO has come and gone
you know the toaster still love having
wedding questions for us and I just
wanted to call us with someone that I
love and it's not because you could
invite anyone else to go well yes and no
it was that but I also was just like I
would rather it be means than like
meeting someone else today for the first
time especially for the first show back
we took a nice long break much-needed
for me personally I think I gained a
pound a day ever since I left the show
so I must look way different than two
weeks ago but it's good we're just
newlyweds you look beautiful
Thanks means no one ever tells you about
like the newlywed 15 you know and it's
not even doesn't even happen in a year
it happens in the months after your
wedding happens in 48 hours
yeah but what else you know as long as
we shut it for the weddin like that's
when it counts so now we have a little
starting today and if you guys watch
Ben's stories like today starts the real
Kito season shedding season as they like
to call it does it sorry mark
in Denmark is that what it starts for
you today - yeah that feels right you
know yeah it really is like Monday it
really is Monday it's the first Monday
in but March anyway so how's everyone
been we've been great we were in Utah
skiing eating watching movies it was
just a really nice time what'd you think
love it Utah's great the views are
amazing and I love being with the family
so much fun it was so much fun everyone
are we taking a mini moon by now we've
abandoned the mini moon like that was
the mini moon and I mean no we're not
taking like a mini moon but we are
planning our honeymoon in the fall
because we can't go anywhere anytime
soon we have to work we have to work we
got it get ready we got a financially
pay for the mini moon the only one so
that's what we put the mini moon to
right you know you combine the two yeah
well we're going to call you in a few
weeks for a romantic weekend in upstate
New York so maybe that would be our mini
men well maybe maybe not maybe not I'm
big Coley finally asked me to like come
participate in an alumni event as like a
notable along which I mean I'm so
honored but also like it's about time
you know what took them so long I don't
know but the toast is coming up on its
one-year anniversary anniversary
anniversary which is exciting it's big
times what's the official date April 9th
Wow
yeah crazy what can happen in a year big
year it was a big year for us marriage
how does it feel being a husband how
does it feel wearing a wedding ring
it feels really good I like I like
jewelry this is nice it is it feels
right and makes you really just look so
mature it does and now I have like so
much ring swag for girls to marry with
so many girl with no jewelry I got some
swag now swaggy hands he looks great
thank you I mean thank you for of course
they're getting those for me anyways we
have such a great show for you today
because not only are we gonna hit you
with the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast but we're
also gonna recap all the things that we
did all the movies that we watch all the
TV shows that we watched and then we
have a ton of questions for memes so we
will get to them how do you remember to
look I think having camera well you
don't have to if this isn't the office
like it's very conversational look I'm
gonna be like this the whole show and
that's and that's normal okay and just
do what feels natural to you you know
it's a very laid-back show take your
shoes off take your clothes off without
further ado here are the Fast Five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast okay I'm so used to doing
it with my own voice
um the big news of the weekend everyone
JLo and a rod are engaged j-rod is tying
the knot she said yes a rod announced on
Instagram captioning a photo of the
massive engagement ring on Saturday
night JLo posted the same photo with
many heart emojis and a reps a rods rep
confirmed the good news to page six okay
I'm so happy they're getting married
because now when I say j-rod I'm just
talking about them at it as a couple as
opposed it's hard to say JLo a rod I
always say she brought a low but
couldn't you set j-rod before they
needed to be yeah yo first well now
there's like a couple you know now their
symbiotic it's like now how we're zakir
oh right but everyone was always calling
us that jacket is a trucker that's our
name Jack and Zaki yeah you know it's
confusing it's true and now I don't know
if JLo is going on a bachelorette party
and she needs a hashtag but I suggest
JLo no mo it'd be good that would be
good it's amazing what our wedding has
done for the world of love right you
know just people popping the question I
know nothing right I mean our wedding
has sparked like a lot of just romance
in the air you know there were some cute
hookups at the wedding some people have
gone on dates but then recently your
best friend you know just got engaged
she did show it to Billy and I just feel
like weddings here Billy and Taylor
Mazel Tov I feel like weddings have that
effect of you know really getting people
excited love is in the air people can
feel it people can see the good that can
come out of it right out of marriage
because you only really hear about the
bad it's true
but every time someone gets engaged or
one of your friends are one I need my
friends not yet but they always say like
I wish I'd done it sooner you know
they're like no one ever is like I wish
well as some people say I wish that
waited late but we're not but we're
waiting longer you know I wish I never
did it we're not there yet
yeah well keep you posted but anyways
Mazel Tov - these two I'm really happy
for them this seems like a logical step
they seem like they're already you know
Adam Sandler and Drew Barrymore and
they're a blended family I'm happy for
the kids I'm happy for the kids to like
they got like a really cool like vibe
going on and they brought it would be a
cool stuff dad for sure and Jules yeah
really is a win-win all around yeah so
I'm excited for them and their wedding
is definitely gonna be extra because
honestly they're really [ __ ] extra and
yes of course because they're like the
biggest tarts ever but also they show up
to everything yeah it's kind of just
reminding me how much I'm kind of an
don't like them like there there's
something going on I don't know maybe
there I like them but they just their
own camera it's always for the camera
yeah and it's like they go to the
Grammys they go to Oscars and like
neither of them is nominee to program
you're an Oscar right now so they didn't
need to be there Jerrod is so hot right
now but who doesn't like going getting
dressed up and going up and also made me
like they were in that point in their
relationship right before you got
engaged where it's like okay like what's
next and they just kept going out and
thirsting it out maybe they'll take some
private time now though I think that
they actually did a good job of like
they didn't post too much they it was a
great picture great ring great ring
great sunset
that's a JLo caliber ring definitely
she's that's like worthy of the woman
that she is
I'm glad you approve because otherwise
we would have had to talk to a rod I
said what you know now with celebrities
posting their jewelry on Instagram
especially their rings like it just
reminds me of kim kardashian i'm a
lesson that she learned the hard way and
I don't know why any celebrity would
like put a target on their back like
that especially because robberies in LA
are so rampant if you watch The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills it's just
like everyone's getting robbed and then
to just put your new jewelry out on
Instagram like I don't know I just it
would give me it would give me the
willies it's great for the diamond
industry I literally saw a sponsored
post of that ring really
and then you swipe through and it's the
picture of of his post so like was it
from the jeweler I don't know what real
diamond or it was like you know already
it was like get your health yeah it was
like yeah yeah yeah I was like get your
your your own JLo ring yeah do you want
your own JLo and of course who doesn't
imagine instead of a band if you wore
like a big rock I would love that he
wanted to he wanted to get like a Super
Bowl ring for his wedding ring which I
would have been fine with but I just
knew you wouldn't wear it every day yeah
but I like the idea of it yeah like a
bunch like I'll rock the pinkie ring
European just feel like
you know bring bring the pinkie ring
back bring back the pinky ring okay
I think if anyone can do it means you
can and you know if you ever need a
platform to promote yourself on tell
anyway you know where to find us okay
next up in some other exciting wedding
news
Lea Michele has married her fiance sandy
rice Lea Michele is a married woman I'm
sure Claudia somewhere is smiling from
ear to ear in her sleep on Saturday the
former Glee star weds fiance's Andy Ryan
an intimate ceremony in Northern
California what we are so excited to be
married and grateful to be surrounded by
our family and friends and most of all
we're so happy to spend the rest of our
lives together
join my Michelle's former co-stars
Darren Criss and Emma Roberts the
wedding comes less than a year after
rice the president of women's clothing
brand Ayr popped the question yes
Michelle caption a photo of her four
carat engagement ring last spring these
two seem really cute and really normal
and there's nothing more normal than a
one-year engagement even though in
hindsight it's too long I love the names
Andy
you do yeah just feels right yes like a
nice Jewish boy she's a nice she's
Jewish too so that's a cute couple it's
great little great for the community
again it's just amazing what I guess
they were engaged before or what right
yeah I think they plan to get they
waiting they waited oh yeah yeah yeah
until after we got married
but I wonder now like who in the
audience there is like has the lovebug
you know maybe Emma Roberts is next
she's with the guy from Horror Story
from what our story American Horror
Story American oh is she I think so do
you watch out I don't know I've never
seen it I don't know who her man is I
just have read some lines that are
troubling but I choose to ignore them
okay ah but she has a boyfriend yeah
yeah a longtime boyfriend but she's you
know not that I'm not that you do you
follow her
no do you did you ever watch Glee when
it was on I did and who did you it was
on PBS it was sound bad
who did you like what were your thoughts
I think for the time we were in it was
really cool I think now like it would it
would be really corny like I just think
you know with Riverdale everything is so
much more edgy and I just
I don't think like that would I yeah
that's a very fair assessment do you
ever watch screen Queens I did not know
hmm that's gonna be a problem for us
okay it's the best show that's ever
happened to the world yeah with two M's
or one with one end and do you remember
when we started dating in that and we
were talking like around Halloween yes
and then I dressed up as scream queens
for Halloween so you should know and I
remember oh my gosh I know the show I
see this question before cuz when we
were talking right before Halloween when
we were just you know flirting in the
office by the water cooler
you were like asking me what I was gonna
be for Halloween and I said from scream
queens and you hadn't watched a show you
would think he would have like gone home
and watched it so you could have
something to talk to me about but maybe
he just didn't like me at lunch I wonder
if I watch an episode because the - I
might have really I might have you would
remember it's like that premium anyways
very happy for Lea Michele and in some
other wedding news chance the rapper has
also married his longtime girlfriend
Kirsten Corley chance the married man
chance the rapper is a married man the
hip hop star 25 he's young but his
longtime girlfriend Kirsten Corley on
Saturday at the resort at Pelican Hill
in Newport Beach California people
confirms guests included Kim
kardashian-west and her husband Kanye
who have been longtime friends of chance
a source tells people comedian Dave
Chappelle was also in attendance
according to E news
although the rapper has yet to share any
photos from compares nuptials he did
leave a comment underneath a handful of
images and videos taken from the
ceremony which were posted online by the
shade room I did see that they got like
I guess paparazzi photos and he
commented these photos came from some
lanes wait till you see the official
ones he must have an exclusive or
something with People magazine and he
just like doesn't want not to cut into
his change my suit though he seems like
about that that was the same comment I
had right when when photos are being
leaked yeah it was blames these lames
yeah except it was like all people that
we knew and we were like happy to leave
them what are your thoughts because I
saw pictures of Kanye like he was
wearing like what looked to be like a
just black jeans and a short sleeve
button black button-down okay at the
wedding do you know what the dress code
was what was what was Kim wear well
she's always running dressed up I didn't
see their alpha I didn't see Kim Jim
Post anything coming show put a picture
up right
we are there yeah but then like I didn't
even see a picture of it I don't know
where yeah fine one but it's Kanye so I
mean he could get away with anything he
can but maybe it was just a casual what
day of the week on Saturday
was it Saturday day was it Saturday
maybe but he did like a luncheon he
seems like a luncheon kind of guy KitKat
and I think also like when chemists say
the dress code was festive dressy casual
dressy casual which is a dress code that
makes no sense to confuse you right
cause like if you spend somewhere and
the dress code was dressy casual suit
dressy or is it casual that was the
dress code of our rehearsal dinner and
like no one I got like no one knew what
to wear except in the end everyone it's
always better to be I think overdressed
than underdressed totally anyway so what
I was gonna say say the dress code was
festive party attire and Kim comes like
black-tie you know to the nines and
Kanye comes dressed down together the
couples average isn't is in line with
the dress code so I think actually
that's you know part of being a team
it's good to know the next time we go to
a wedding than I have be one where
flexibility you want to wear a
short-sleeve button-down yeah that could
be cool also speaking of Kim and Kanye
because they just can't miss an
opportunity to talk about them and they
weren't in the news this weekend
unfortunately except they've been
posting more videos from church and now
church has I gone to there I'm pretty
sure it's their backyard or someone's
backyard and Kanye was singing jesus
walks with the chorus you had an
interesting theory on this I think he in
typical Kanye fashion this is live
rehearsals for a toy that's coming up
and this whole time we've been watching
it and we didn't even know what we were
watching but it's it's it's the tour
it's next door I'm so clear for that but
you think he would like use Church you
know I use Church embrace and celebrate
yes I usually in a rehearsal you're like
check one two like five six seven eight
and people are redoing it but do you
think it's just like a natural like he's
not the casual rehearsals yeah they're
what they're working through it as as
they go I love the court I love that but
that would be acquired or
I mean like what looked like there was
like 40 gospel singers yeah amazing
amazing and then with North Fort
knighting in the frontal Italy I see
that I'll go there okay if he goes on to
her the Sunday service tour that would
be really cool really and especially
because everyone who's been seeing these
videos now especially when they were in
that like neon bubble I husband like I
want to go to church
totally maybe he's gonna he's doing like
a church tour you know starting his own
jazz a guy you got you have mature life
yeah I mean it's got that like vibe I
could see that one of the toasters had
commented on the video of them singing
that it was like Kanye was starting his
like Kanye verse Carlin's
and then tour each show would only be on
a Sunday so he would do a Sunday and
everything no it'd be tour Church yeah
sure sure I don't go I'm free yeah okay
speaking but more music interesting
story that I didn't expect Queen but I
didn't expect Queen music video director
Bohemian Rhapsody sequel is being
discussed the director of dozens of
Queen music videos says that the band
and its management are lining up behind
a sequel to smash hit Freddie Mercury
film Bohemian Rhapsody Rudi Dolezal who
directed videos for the band and became
close with mercury during his life told
page six in an interview oh we did put
up a photo of Kim looks great I mean
literally she could wear anything and I
did she look great oh I guess I can
imagine what Kanye you said black pants
in a galaxy though what do you think
about just shorts a collared shirts in
general they're kind of a brave move but
now I'm conscious yeah I think they
should be worn more but no one's figured
out how because you look like Book of
Mormon yeah yeah I've done the short
sleeve like a blazer look and people
don't know that I have that's nice yeah
which is nice but um it's a shame cuz
that's it yeah for those shirts cuz like
they are very functional very function
don't want to always wear long sleeves
and you roll them up 3/4 of the way
anyway so why not just cut the sleeves
off and call it that why not go why not
sleeveless
yeah I could see it nice why not
off-the-shoulder why not
we should start a line speaking of the
fact that it's almost summer today is
such a beautiful day beautiful and it's
getting me really excited for summer
that's so great I'm excited that you're
excited I know cuz usually I don't love
like warm weather I don't care about the
weather but I'm ready this time you know
and I think I'm gonna try I'm gonna like
get back to live method and like we're
quito season starts today and it would
be nice to be like in shape like have
one good summer it'd be nice that's what
I've been saying like imagine having
like not that I intend to but a six-pack
or going to the beach and like being
excited to be animating soon it's it's a
shocking thought but I don't know I
think I'm gonna hurdle I think I may try
it no one does that
okay that's Bohemian Rhapsody the
director for many music videos for the
band who became close with mercury told
page six in an interview about Queens
legendary manager Jim beach aka
Miami I'm sure he has plans to it was
for a sequel that starts with Live Aid
Dolezal added that the follow-up film is
now quote being heavily discussed in the
Queen family Beach also produced
Bohemian Rhapsody which has made more
than 870 million dollars worldwide the
rock biopic won four Oscars last month
and was nominated for Best Picture okay
this is really shocking because I just
feel like sequels are always a bad idea
and I understand why they happen because
one stepsister act - that was really
good was that the best sequel then
sometimes sequels are always bad but
then the trace the trip the treichel is
always amazing High School Musical 3
hangover 3 you know so we can't have it
a third without the second three and
also what we were just watching Aquaman
and we are saying that there's
definitely at me a sequel because it's
the number one box office movie ever for
DC Comics for DC Comics cuz also does
that take into account inflation because
obviously when ticket prices are now $20
yeah there's they're making more money
than when tickets were a penny Gone with
the Wind fabulous I just I was I was a
DC no I'm just saying in general like
when we compare like the Titanic even to
its Wonder Woman's a great point gone
with the wind I just want to make sure
we're counting inflation and so it
shouldn't be like how much money it made
it should be how many tickets were sold
but even still now that's changing we
just watch Spokane
in Rhapsody on Fandango now we didn't
even buy tickets doesn't even account
for that
exactly I'm sure they like you know
really fudged numbers
Nielsen whatever anyways Bohemian
Rhapsody they're talking about with me
number two which ordinarily I'd be
really excited about because I loved
Bohemian Rhapsody but then we watched it
when we were in Utah and no one liked it
mhm and then it made me realize like it
was a music video it was a really long
music video just to put dialog in
between yeah
which some people which is fun but then
like when everyone was tearing it apart
and then also I mean I'm down for a
Bohemian Rhapsody sequel just so we have
like a Freddie Mercury movie that's not
directed by Bryan Singer and then
everyone can really enjoy it more but
like what would the sequel have like
what did we not so I guess it would
they're saying it would start with Live
Aid right where it ended and then but
wouldn't it all just be kind of sad and
also they kind of ruined it for
themselves because in real life Freddie
Mercury didn't know that he was sick
before Live Aid so now the whole sequel
would be him being sicken and getting
worse or getting better like it's just
it wouldn't it would automatically like
be kind of sad yeah you know it seems
like something that should come with the
DVD when it comes out like right an
added bonus features bonus Boheme
additional ending yeah or I remember I
read because Sacha Baron Cohen was
supposed to play Freddie Mercury which
would have been really amazing now that
they could do they could do a sequel
with Sasha as Freddie let me do the
whole movie again but apparently he
didn't he he didn't wind up doing it cuz
he was clashing with the band members
who wanted the movie to be about Queen
after Freddie Mercury's death and Sasha
Baron Cohen was like nobody cares and
the movie didn't wind up being a
Marriott but maybe that's what the
sequel will be maybe they finally get
their way maybe that's the only way that
they were able to shut them up was like
okay we'll do it as a sequel listen
it'll probably do well and it'll be the
number one grossing movie of all time
sure and that kind of brings me to
Aquaman which we were so excited to
watch as you know Jason Momoa is my
celebrity crush and memes has accepted
it and you've embraced it I don't get it
personally but it's fine you know it's
not like that in shape
he's got like a you know long hair no
it's scruffy beard yeah it's a weird I
had definitely a weird taste um so we
were so excited to see it and we finally
were able to like rent it on iTunes
they finally let us rent it for
twenty-five twenty-five dollars and like
and they could have done anything we
would have liked it and we did but it
was really disappointing it was like
really it was really corny it was like a
parody of yeah a superhero movie at
times and like he was doing his best and
he was great but there was just
something about it that was like is this
a joke
even like this script was bad yeah I
have a theory with all these green
screen like centric movies like I just
think it's really tough to produce a
good film because literally if you see
like any of these Instagram accounts
that show you like behind the scenes of
the movies it's like you know Jerry the
camera guy I'm like a green screen like
bodysuit and like someone like Jason is
literally talking to him is if he's like
a 10 foot like serpent serpents right so
either the acting's gotten worse or just
the special effects are just so like
high tech that it's just allowed riders
not to write that's good because they
can make anything visually come to life
right I thought like the special like
the the world that they created was
almost like too good it felt like a
animated movie it was like we were
watching people real people live people
in an animated movie
I was like one of those is those quotes
that you see on the DVDs it was almost
too good no it was I mean I never saw
avatar and I don't really watch a lot of
movies that are like sci-fi in different
worlds but I feel like they're able to
transport you to this world and you
understand like how things work and the
rules of you know how fish and people
breathe underwater or whatever and I
just thought was weird everyone's
underwater and then they come above
water and they're just like what I
thought the premise was weak I mean like
the villain in that movie was earth that
was the land yeah and also the villain
was his
and then it turns out that you know he
just needed a mother's love so soon as a
hug he just needed a hug yeah I'd like
to me a superhero movie is only as good
as the villain my was no good villain in
that movie that's fair but yeah because
it it was kind of annoying that turned
out to be his brother like the old
Batman's like the Heath Ledger rest in
peace like that was such a good super
hair movie because there was such a good
villain
that's an interesting cake well you know
rami malek is gonna be a villain he's
gonna be a Bond villain really mm-hmm
what do you think about was Freddie
Mercury I think he'll be a really good
villain he's like kind of weird
he's a scare I was watching some stuff I
saw I think I know the video does the
mint the hotel video yeah he was doing a
promotion for a hotel and he was talking
about himself and it was like first
things it was really weird
I watched it on I think nightly pop was
like talking about it and for me it was
really funny also speaking of sequels it
came out that greatest showman is
working on a sequel with Hugh Jackman
and it's like there is such a thing as
too much of a good thing
I believe well they're doing a sequel
they're doing Broadway I'd rather them
to you they're doing the greatest show
girl ooh I'm talentless good thing I
would be more for that's equal than
Bohemian Rhapsody sync sequel because
there's at least with that it's there's
new ideas new songs new concepts yeah
this is just now there's something like
there's more for us to to know and you
can make it up you know you can only
take so many creative liberties with
yeah a true story except the story of PT
Barnum is technically true also did
someone they heard my stomach growl do
you hear that did I didn't you don't
want my stomach growls all the time on
the show but I get this I'm extra hungry
that was the first time you heard it
that's the beginning of Kito's season
Wow
yeah Oh someone asked who's your
celebrity crush ah Jackie oh thanks
memes but like who's your a list
celebrity crush
hmm
Sharyl blossom you that's not anymore
she's you're over here yeah I'm over
here yeah I feel that I'll get back to
you on that one okay yeah is it Amber
Heard now from the movie she was looking
snatched she's not a great actress I had
no idea um but she's great looking shoes
okay I'll get back to you okay
toasters you're always are you sure it's
not me even though I'm just I told you
it was you you didn't like that answer
oh because I'm wife of the year exactly
wife of the month the wifey Awards don't
be good the award show that would be a
bit or job that I'll win away see
because I'm going to take cooking
classes next month and I'm so excited
cuz premium content right there premium
content and you know it's time and you
know it will just make us like be so
much healthier and save so much money in
the means in theory but in the meantime
daily harvest has been saving my wifey
ass because it is the most nutritional
on-the-go delicious thing even though
it's you know frozen and all you have to
do is heat it up daily harvest delivers
carefully sourced chef crafted smoothies
savory bowls overnight oats and more
built on fruits and vegetables
everything stays fresh in your freezer
until you're ready to eat it so we've
had the bowls and the smoothies and it's
just so good and fresh considering it's
frozen food technically so we're loving
it and until I learn how to cook this is
gonna hold us over chews for more than
50 nourishing options for any time of
day ready to blend smoothies savory
harvest bowls soups and more each single
serving cups takes one step to prepare
just add water or milk to a smoothie or
heat up a harvest bowl I'll call go to
Dale Daley harvest comm and enter promo
code toast to get three cups free in
your first box that's promo code toast
for three free three free daily harvest
cups at daily harvest dot-com daily
harvest com well with a promo code code
toast that was a mouthful yeah they're
so good I'm I guess I'm just kind of
rusty in speaking today I've had a lot
of like you know megyn kelly time to
teleprompter flubs and you've only
called me out on a few of them but it's
it's hard listen I getting back
I shouldn't host the morning
so for three years and I did three years
yeah I've only been doing this for two
years
I know listen if you ever need any
advice let me know stuff you were saying
we should have done vocal exercises
before the show I would watch Claudia's
video that she goes that was so funny
it's hard on it tip of the tongue tip of
the tongue try it tip of the tongue the
tongue tip of the tongue tip of the
tongue tip and Sharpay Evans no there's
a lot of spit required yeah Jesse's her
Sharpay cuz she really was quite
talented okay next story how are people
liking this I think people are
thoroughly enjoying it they like in my
side because I it's probably the
superfly they're saying you're so funny
oh wow
I haven't had a chance to look at all
the comments cuz yeah I'm just like
doing it all over here yeah and I'm also
like trying to do a job my job and
trying to impress my husband and I don't
know how I'm doing a good job
whatever Kylie Jenner and Jordan Woods
did not reunite after Tristan Thompson
drama after all okay considering this is
his story just revolving around fake
news usually I wouldn't report on it but
I feel personally invested because this
story originated in the morning toasters
Facebook group where just everything
premium happens a toaster saw Kylie
having pancakes with a brunette friend
and they put it in the group and it was
is it Jordan
is it not turn out not to be Jordan I
believe it was Kylie's friend Heather
Sanders yes but the L email picked it up
you know cuz they're like just snooping
in the toasters he picked it up snooping
in the toasters and you would think they
would be a little more diligent about
their Kardashian news and they reported
that it was Jordan woods when it wasn't
and I mean if you're a toaster you
already knew that but I just the story
really here is that not only our daily
Melanie news just like combing through
the toasters for premium content they're
also getting it wrong actually the real
story is the real question is what kind
of pancakes did she have that is the
real question I think they were it was
too far to tell but they were like oh we
like no way I feel like Kylie eats good
you know oh my good good like first of
all she has that Jenner metabolism yeah
so I think she can eat what she wants
for the most part and she's always
eating like cereal and milk like they
scootsie she also cooks a lot I feel
like if she's going to a pancake house
she's getting chocolate chip pancakes
feel like that's the next industry
because they just sent out says she's
the youngest billionaire yes they did or
so up on your news yep I think that's
the next industry that eventually she'll
break food yeah I mean if she did a
cooking show or cooking pot I mean that
would blow blow off once I get into
cooking maybe I'll watch her show learn
some tips think about it she would do so
much she would do really well but she
doesn't really love being on TV or
cosmetics that now you can eat yeah
that's the next gen all of the
Kardashians I think are actually really
good chefs it's surprising that they
don't have like I think Chloe had a show
a cooking cooking centric show at one
point uh it was like drinking it was
kocktails with khloé'
yeah I guess one of them could have a
cooking show but that's a lot they don't
like need to do stuff you know yeah
that's true
and it's a lot to a helmet hood and show
not only do up to a cut gift to talk for
30 minutes which I as we've learned
today is very hard and I mean she she
doesn't need to and she's not thirsty
whatsoever that's true so I think all
right well if anyone knows what kind of
pancakes it's a yeah if the waiter wants
to you know side with a fruit on top no
[ __ ] fruit Wow okay
just pancakes with syrup what are your
favorite type of thinking I don't really
eat pancakes a lot because it's like if
I'm indulging it's not happening in the
morning but I didn't go chocolate chip
for sure that's my wife that's your wife
means likes pancakes means like things
when I'm in the pancake mood for sure
yeah yeah I remember when we first
started going out and we went to brunch
and he ordered his meal and he was like
and can I have a side of Pancakes and I
was like that's the biggest move ever I
didn't know that was the thing now we do
it all the time cuz now we're just big
you can get a side of anything
I know Shapiro tried to get a side of
pasta somewhere I think that's a meal
that makes sense
no it doesn't it's not a side salad I'm
sorry pasta that's not a thing you get
anything on the side Cipriani
a side of pasta I would do it yeah any
good establishment customer's always
right
true yes sure I mean what I like the
pasta with the side
that's a big deal no more pasta for a
while means yeah very sad except we ate
a lot this weekend while we like to talk
women comes out yeah we've eaten a lot
like animating a lot behave I'm just
trying to talk lack new names okay are
you ready you got our fifth and final
story before we just descend into a Q&A
of me mersen's husband edition oh wow
the newest in me mersen's technology
okay
last story Jaguar attacks a woman taking
a selfie at a Wildlife World zoo in
Litchfield Park a woman is recovering
after she was attacked by a Jaguar at
wildlife world zoo aquarium and Safari
Park Saturday evening rural Metro fire
crews who responded to the scene said
the woman was trying to take a selfie
near the fence of the Jaguar enclosure
when the cat reached out and attacked
her arm officials officials said she was
transported to the hospital with
non-life-threatening injuries
Adam Wilkerson who recorded video of the
incident said he was with his mother and
his two kids here the Jaguar enclosure
when he heard screaming and so the
Jaguars claws grasping a woman's hand
quote it seems like pandemonium
everyone's yelling for help he wrote in
a reddit post he said his mother
distracted the Jaguar with a water
bottle and it let go of the woman we are
still in shock from it all he wrote this
is so crazy and just like the dangers of
selfies know no bounds you know have a
couple questions okay was there a selfie
stick definitely not because actually
mistake number one
somebody said wouldn't even help in this
situation because yourself to get as
close to the Jaguar as you as you want
the her arm might have been more
protected ya know where arm only goes
out so far go you go more further out
than no but if you're taking a selfie
you're gonna extend your arm as far as
possible actually probably further than
if you're using a selfie stick because
you don't have to okay next question it
was dark it said it was yet the zoo was
about to close so do you think she used
flash now probably disturbs that scare
the yeah
all around and you know as someone like
I will do it for the gram and then I'm
you know as thirsty as they come like
this is where we draw the line people
yeah it's a bit risky and did she even
get the selfies did she even get the
shot I don't know I'm glad that there's
no life-threatening injury like she's
gonna
okay and I was the judge the Jaguars are
kid he didn't put the the Jaguar down or
anything because it wasn't her fault
what kind of fence is that by the way I
don't li she went behind the fence
someone saying she stepped over the
barrier
she's definitely a [ __ ] and like Cersei
is hella and you know what like there's
other ways to get premium content and
honestly even a selfie with a Jaguar
like who cares actually that's kind of
cool I don't know I wouldn't care yeah
yeah I want to selfie with a Jaguar I'll
just fly down the Florida and go to you
know preseason game yeah very good yeah
very good Jacksonville Jaguars are those
awards fans out there
JX yeah like me Jax totally I'm a
favorite team I really know the Cowboys
are because it's my husband's favorite
it is okay are you ready to be in the
hot seat it's hearty hot it's already
hot yeah it is it does get kind of warm
under here this weather I don't know
don't call us out it's genuine it's warm
under there it's genuine means okay
question from Toastmaster general Ally
Mahajan how has last week been as a
husband great question oh not week I
guess it's been three weeks now it's
been great I've loved every moment
married life is fantastic you feel
different definitely different in a good
way it's just there's just less stress
yeah less stress it's like even though
I've gained ten pounds I feel like I
lost 20 yeah interesting seven down
twenty ten math isn't my strong suit
either today okay means do this is an
important question and like I don't want
to trigger you or anything but trigger
just have to ask do you like it when the
Italian and American campers show up or
do you get annoyed if I was just seeing
what everyone else saw I would love it I
think it's genius it's hilarious
you're so creative and imaginative and
really creative genius' cute but the
issue is is that I see all the behind
the scenes all the outtakes
oh so many outtakes well the outtakes
consists of you not filming yourself but
just being an Italian member and I guess
technically it is weird like to be like
a 20 year old man no shade married to an
Italian camper you know yeah that's a
bit weird but I mean she's pretty mature
she drives for uber
she'll better she's trying to figure out
what to pack for this camp and she
really made a spawn shot your after
party she does she turned it up my
videos hilarious okay what will come
first getting a dog cousin for Theo so
just a cousin please rude or having a
baby we know we talked I think at this
point because for a while for a little
bit we were actually really considering
getting a dog a cousin for Theo and then
after I may be sad him for the weekend I
realize that it was just not in the
cards for us yeah um so at this point we
aren't really talking about getting a
dog just spending more time with do is
but we aren't really talking about
having a baby so no but like we're
talking about having maybe not anytime
soon but more than we're we're to having
it talking about having a dog isn't
really even on the table anymore we kind
of like moved on for now we can bring
back the dog conversation we already
have a name for him
do you remember well you decided toasty
no don't give it away
toasty though you can't name the dog
before you have it it's bad luck but
just a spoiling you have a name for it
the dog is Italian okay remember the
name I do it was a good one ah which
dress from the wedding was your favorite
you answered this question on patreon
but now I'm curious if you have the same
answer I think it was the second dress
that's what you said yeah yeah that's
crazy imagine if I because I almost
didn't wear a second dress cuz I didn't
I got it the week before imagine if I
never even wore in imagine and then you
were just stuck with one dress that you
didn't like just kidding I love the
dress Peter okay - who do you like
better the American camper or the
Italian camper
hmm a dyin camper yeah she's like a swag
well actually but that was just she's
just funny
she's just funnier yeah the American
camber are like she's cute but she's so
dead right okay how have you perfected
your technique of being a professional
Instagram photographer slash husband
Instagram husband well I've always been
a creative director in life so no I
enjoy it I really do
I'm a behind-the-scenes guy so this fits
right into that job title I enjoy it
do you have any tips for any women or
men out there who find themself in the
position of crouched on the floor and
taking a photo for significant crushing
tiger hidden names hidden things exactly
[Music]
listen to your significant other
definitely get the angle that they want
and then do you do something that
they're not expecting and you never know
you might find gold we found all of them
a couple photo shoots we have a couple
of our big shoots that we've done 11:11
Make A Wish ooh well justice for the
girls which has been our wish which has
really been happening a lot recently we
eleven eleven every day we make a wish
and for a while I was watching Ferg beat
you bad Gucci bag Gucci bag got there
for my birthday because I wanted to wish
for something tangible so I can know if
my wish came true and it did now we are
watching for dresses for the girls who
have been victims of art Kelly and it's
kind of happening you know things are
moving we watched the Gayle King
interview that was very good and the one
on SNL or the one we watched both yeah
the one on SNL I was hilarious
where's the camera my from New York no
if you hadn't watched I mean he's great
SNL this week was was pretty good you
didn't love you to Selma I thought he
did a great job I think he messed up a
lot I didn't notice maybe I was so
distracted by his good looks
all right he's he's he's okay he's cool
he'd be cool yeah but anyways the you
have to watch the opening of SNL this
week so good
they just had so many good in tune
sketches Gweneth Paltrow was on it
yep even though I told I didn't
I understand why she was like really
making fun of herself in her business
you know she may just like like that
sketch character a lot and write she
asked but it just looks like the people
that work for her and don't know what
they're selling because they're selling
a bunch of hooey like I said that's what
it is I think it's really smart cool and
I bet her stocks just went up
perhaps her who's there it is does memes
ever want his picture taken how do you
ever ask me to take your picture I don't
know who wants to see this stop you're
so cute
but I feel like I'm not unless we were
with like a celebrity or something that
you wanted a picture with no I mean a
picture is worth a thousand words but so
but I'm not a good reader so who needs
all those words yeah means do I snore no
you don't snore you there um is there
anything we're glad we didn't do at our
weddings say that I come is there
anything we're glad that we did not do
at our wedding I'm glad it didn't fall
I'm glad I did my only one of us can
take up I'm glad I didn't miss the glass
when breaking it totally and I'm glad I
didn't throw up on the dance floor cuz
you know for a while the jury was out we
should have gotten branded throw up bags
just in case now I mean cute yeah who is
your favorite housewife that's a great
question because means it's kind of a
housewives kind of sort like you used to
watch Bravo before we even started
dating yeah I love Bravo andis a genius
[Music]
you've been kind of behind though like
I've been watching without you just
because you're such a busy man I just
maybe I'm wrong to just oh there's like
too many different franchises now and
it's hard to really get into one it's
like even New York which is like slated
to be the best season ever just because
of all of the real-life drama the
premiere episode it's like okay now I
have to start caring about these people
again it takes a minute I firmly ain't
you have to catch up I'm Everly Hills it
is it is the season of all seasons
really mm-hmm
Lisa Vanderpump is going down by the way
she's owning Bravo right now Lisa yeah
that's and that's the problem
yeah we'll talk about it
Vanderpump for example can you imagine
if there was like eight different
franchises of Vanderpump it would not be
what it is today that's true like if
there was all these different
restaurants across the country so I
think I think oversaturating how do you
feel about the Real Housewives of Dallas
as a Dallas man honestly I haven't
watched that franchise as much just
because I lived it I was a Dallas
housewife earlier on in my career and no
I love I love the fact that they're
showcasing my city my JD do you think
you're doing a good job like I've got
many good spots in restaurants I haven't
been well you're not into I hope they
are I mean you know Dallas pretty well
yeah sometimes they'll go somewhere and
I'm like we have to go there yeah sound
looks good but to give that white line
looks crisp take it back to your initial
question favorite housewife
I love Nene I knew you're gonna say that
although I saw last night that she
unfollowed Andy on Instagram no yeah I
don't know why that's crazy that you saw
that and I didn't where'd you see that
he posted like a video on on Instagram
Wow yeah he is an Instagram yeah oh can
you follow him yeah
who are some of your favorite people to
follow in general yeah
on Instagram not around town good
morning toes Jackie oh problems girl
with no job boy with no job pup with no
job my gosh way Olivia Osprey tiffany
thornton i don't know if you know her i
don't know if you're familiar with her
work i don't know if you know that joke
I'll tell explain when we got home
hungover and hungry great page yeah you
actually solid hungover and hungry
before we started dating really yeah you
were like one time I was probably like
two weeks after we started dating you
like showed me something you're like
hungover how you were like isn't this
funny this page it was like that's niche
that's so funny
how's that page done it's quite quiet
still hungover
still hungover still hungry when such
how do you say I love you this actually
keeps story because you said it less
than a week after we started dating
because we like went out everyone knows
he went out
with Ben and Zak and Claudia and that's
when like Zach and I you know in middle
school style found out through other
people that we liked each other and then
like from that night every night the
rest of the week we went out like yeah
I'm like spent like all night you know
talking and getting to know each other
and so then the following week just like
one week after the original group date
the grouper you told me you loved me I
did it was really cute and I was like so
shocked I was like there's no way it's
like it was true this guy's nuts
oh yeah it was it turned out to be true
but I remember I was like tying Becky on
the phone I was like I was like and then
something like like kind of weird happen
because like I couldn't even process
that you said it because I was like
there's no way that you meant it but you
didn't my dreams very sweet what was the
moment that you knew that you were in
love it's a bit too personal of a moment
to talk about okay but I feel the same
way yeah when you know it you know okay
maybe I'll tell me later definitely uh
Zack did you witness my concussion or if
not how did you find out about it I I
heard about it it was the concussion
heard around the world unfortunately I
was a bit intoxicated at that point
that's good though because if you were
to sober you would have been so worried
and then someone someone smart and sober
would have made me go to the hospital
which I probably should have but then
then I would have been ruined it all
worked out thankfully but yeah I mean
definitely hearing about it the next day
I was not happy yeah no boy no yeah um
what's a deal breaker must have in the
next part mini you move into so we are
moving which is like pretty abrupt even
though we knew the apartment that we're
in now was really just like a temporary
solution and we knew we didn't want to
stay there more than a year but then we
got like kind of comfortable and we're
like let's stay another year and then we
realized we had totally outgrown it and
now we're like looking for a new place
we just need more space more closet
space I would say yeah it's the biggest
thing but we have life and we need a
closet space right now we do we just
have a lot of things though and we need
um another
through that would be ideal yeah there's
not like too much overlap but when there
is it's very good layout it's so that we
can be on different islands if we want
yeah we do I said on Mike how many but
German he spends all its time on the
couch did any of your friends or family
give you memorable marriage advice a lot
of good advice you know they never go to
bed angry at each other which I think
we've gotten really good at I don't
agree with that piece of advice I feel
like sometimes you just go to bed angry
and you wake up and you've forgotten
about it as opposed to working it out
that night when it's like it doesn't
need to be worked out cuz it's gonna
work itself out so it's not that big to
begin with you know respectfully
disagree okay
I'm using that's like a classic piece of
advice that I actually don't think is
always true yeah I just don't think
going to bed when you know you have
thoughts on your mind like there's just
that's just you've got something to say
say it I know sometimes it's like going
to bed like when you need to go to the
bathroom but like not yeah and then like
you have to go so badly
yeah we sometimes pee in the bed Oh God
um how did we meet which has never
happened before I just wanna know of
course not
ah no no that's never happened since
we've been together how did we meet we
met at work back in the day we did
there's a song about it it's called
forever noon day it's a hit song yeah
number one on Soundcloud streaming
worldwide yes you post it again of
course I know so I posted the video so
Zach wrote a song for me for our
one-year anniversary and it was a
country song and typically before that
you would only really written like rap
song so you really like change genres
for me which was so sweet and then he
performed at our wedding and there's a
video of it up on the patreon patron on
such a morning toast and it's really
really premium apparent and you were
really drunk so but it was it made you
really like more loose yeah it's a bit
horrifying to watch but in the moment I
hear people you know thoroughly enjoyed
um if you were serving up premium
content as a podcast host what would
your podcast be about mmm
I think it would be pop culture made
sports meets life meets fashion fashion
yeah sneakers you love sneakers sneakers
that's a fun fact about mine said he's a
sneaker head how many pairs of sneakers
do you think that you have all two
combined in Dallas here everywhere that
you found a place to store them longer a
couple hundred what's a couple is that
two hundred is that eight hundred no
like there'll be three three hundred Wow
and as a secret when you collect sneaks
are them are they meant to be worn no
absolutely not
they're just meant like it's like it's
like playing cards okay you know like
you know you keep them in the box and
nobody's like I collect handbags all
with the attention to be mourn yeah I
don't okay
I'm just curious I guess I don't glite
handbags with the intention of wearing
them just collect them as collectors
items okay was it love at first sight
did you know you're gonna marry him when
you met him the same question for memes
honestly like yeah
Margot Lewin always tells the story I
went to lunch with her the day that we
went out on our grouper and I said to
her I was like I'm either going to marry
him or I will never speak to him again
I'm glad you don't know how it ended
never spoke to him again what about you
means love at first sight do you believe
in it I do actually
there's a couple people in this world
that can vouch for me but as soon as we
wrapped that show I literally turned to
Maxwell
shoutout to z100 and Dom and Andy former
colleagues of mine and I turned to them
when you guys left the studio and I was
like I'm gonna marry that girl and that
was before like that was we were
flirting yeah I just there was just
something there I just knew it that's so
crazy because I really didn't even think
that you like liked me until you knew
that I liked
you but at that point you didn't know
that I like you that's true I don't know
why I said it but I swear to you I said
it I believe you I believe you
that's so crazy anyways thank you for
joining us
that's it that's it because we have to
go look at an apartment and you have to
get to work that's true and we're just
like so happy that you were able to hear
cut be here break down the past five
stories that you needed to know this
morning you know yeah and really like
recap a little bit of the wedding even
though I feel like I've talked about it
like you know so much I feel fully
recapped what about you like still
talking about it
no it's time to like move on except I
think I'm ready to get back to like
posting pictures of it every day really
yeah because like it's just they're so
cute and positive and sweet so if it's
hardly come up with a caption for like
the 20th picture of us like kissing and
you know maybe that's the caption
totally 21st
what else do anything that you want to
plug while you're here this is like a
show for thirst monsters by thirst
monsters with their sponsors and
obviously follow me at Tokyo problems
premium content I'm literally so close
to hitting 200 K but I'm not gonna like
jinx it
because then nothing sadder than hitting
200 and then going back to 199 so I
didn't really want to talk about it but
you know if you're watching like please
follow me it's all I have in life aside
from my wonderful husband and my
precious Nikki sweet just who I need to
go see because it's been so long and I
haven't been talking about him a lot
yeah I was at 200 followers once and
once you go right under 200 and then you
just dip it's just not well your private
man so people can't follow you but
nothing personal anything you want to
show show shell like a petal remote oh
yeah yeah so for those of you that don't
know I run a concert venue in New York
pier 17 we have an amazing outdoor
rooftop venue
Jackie can attest my god it's really
it's sick it is used at the Brooklyn
Bridge behind the stage you're on the
water and we just announced our summer
lineup and it's it's pretty stacked who
can we be excited to see we have Billy
Irish Louie is so hiring so hot right
now who else
that girl Hansel's she's so hot
Lonely Island we have we have passion
pit we have some oldies like squeeze
Ringo Starr our family loves squeeze it
but you didn't know that when you books
them I didn't but we grew up listening
to squeeze every day pulling muscles
from Michelle I can't wait yeah it's
gonna I mean I'll be like at everything
but also it's exciting when it's like
someone that I so tickets are out right
now pier 17 NY calm pier 17 and why.com
yeah very cool I really hope that's the
the domain I think it is that would be
bad but and and it's gonna be great and
we have more shows that are going to be
announced and it's gonna be pretty epic
summer so would you say that they're
gonna be toasty shows 100% super toasty
super toasty yeah exciting so what and
we're about to wrap but would you think
about the toast what do you think about
this our little Instagram show that we
do here I think it's a great show
I think it'll last do you wish that now
are you gonna watch it more often do you
want the politically correct answer or
the real answer you can be real with me
I'm terrified to watch the this episode
because my face has been this whole time
looking at you and it's not your angel
feel like this is like you know gobble
City over here but um let's brave season
out here ya know you've got a great show
thank you I'm very proud of you thanks
and I am happy to host any time well
we'll see what the people say I'll do my
crowd reports a little focus group
testing well let you know how you did
but so far so good I think I'm the one
who is just a mumbo-jumbo Inc all day I
have that effect yeah just so flustered
anyways thank you all for tuning in I
will be back tomorrow with Nick vile
co-hosting with me he will be here to
talk about you know just hosts with me
but also the bachelor finale is on
tonight and tomorrow night so we're just
gonna do like full bachelor talk
tomorrow because what's going down right
now in the bachelor world is actually
crazy I might actually have you watch
with me tonight cuz you watch a lot of
garbage with me but you draw the line at
the bachelor I just doesn't do it for me
but do you know Colton Underwood from
the NFL
I actually know him because he used to
date Aly Raisman yeah they were they
were really cute I think you should
watch tonight with me he's actually a
really great bachelor I was talking
about it with Margot Lewin yesterday and
I just I think he's a perfect bachelor
and I love him so much any what what
makes I think the purpose first of all
he is so good-looking he's just a cutie
and you know that's just like objective
factual statement second of all he's
just doing a really good job in like
handling his emotions and the girls and
third of all he's it he is a former NFL
player whether or not he played a lot
whatever being in the NFL is a huge
accomplishment and he's a real catch and
all these girls lining up to date him
like isn't so far-fetched sometimes they
pick a guy that doesn't have a job old
like they've picked a guy that doesn't
or they have the job they go on The
Bachelorette they quit their job they
come in and surrender or Smasher and
then they're the bachelor and they're
just Instagram famous and like that's
not it's not like so believable all the
time like I believe that a lot of these
girls are really in love with Colton
Underwood because you know I might be
too just kidding I love him for Snitch
I think I love him as my future
brother-in-law I think you would like
him to as a brother-in-law you guys
could vice throw the pigskin
hmm just really get along I think he
would be like coordinating them one of
the guys I wish to Mitch won on the
season but since she didn't I am rooting
for I guess Cassie even though like she
was stone cold last week anyways we will
be discussing all of this tomorrow with
Nick vile and it's just crazy how far
how far we've come I don't think you
even know this like Nick vile used to be
someone in that basket do you see that
right there where there's blac chyna
interested in the guy with the blonde
wig that's true that's blac Chyna okay
and interest some citizens in there and
all these people that we refuse to talk
about on the show because like we can't
stand them and Nick vile was in that
basket and then by the way what a
perfect last name for someone like that
we weren't feeling yeah right but then
we came up on his podcast Claudia and I
and we've talked so much [ __ ] about him
and all he said was like oh I think
those girls don't like me and like he
really had an opportunity to like talk
man [ __ ] about us there's so much you
could say both true and untrue and he
didn't and we were like we really like
grew up in that moment
like wow you can actually like be a nice
person sometimes and like it's it's a
nice look so then he wanted to come on
the show we had him on the show we made
our apologies and now he's co-hosting
with me so it's 2019 anything can happen
we'd love you we will see you tomorrow
thank you may merson's anytime Dave you
did a great job
thank you yeah can't wait to get my Emmy
nomination
oh yeah Daytime Emmy
you